read some of those relationship advice
then Oh bro bro all right so I'm not a
huge I'm not a redditor I just I'm on it
all the time
okay yeah I don't really use reddit I
just you know you're on out I'm just on
at all it's here now
I've been trying to you know I've been
curating my reddit intake and it's first
of all my feet is just [ __ ] up all the
time just bad [ __ ] and this though out
of all the [ __ ] up videos and cringe
videos I see on reddit but the
relationship advice I've read it is so
just unbelievably [ __ ] up these
scenarios I can't oh I doubt that one
that you read you want to explain that
one
which one the [ __ ] one oh yeah that was
on the best of that was another [ __ ]
level dude yeah that was weird the dude
says uh my wife wants to experiment I
obliged and she tries to eat my feces it
started with like their friends like
we're into pegging and then I guess they
kind of got around to like yeah why
don't we try it and then it evolved into
her as he described it trying to catch a
turd falling out of his ass with her
mouth no now that one I'm a little
skeptical that's the first one I've been
skeptical but the way he ended it was
like the end of the pulse is like wow I
didn't expect this to blow up my wife
has seen it that's the worst part yeah
that is the worst part yeah yeah imagine
match [ __ ] scenario dude you
described this whole just intimate
problem intimate weird [ __ ] problem
you're having in your relationship and
then the other party sees it and knows
like not only what you think about it
but how you explain it you know like the
way this guy explained this scenario he
was like yeah wish I was like the turd
was coming out of my ass and I saw that
her mouth was wide open so like I tried
to pull the turd back in so that it
didn't go in her mouth and I pinched off
a little bit
and honey I couldn't look at where it
went because I was so disgusted that it
might have gone in her mouth like
imagine being the wife and reading that
after the fact even get to that point I
would never be squatting over my wife
[ __ ] is coming after my body there is no
one else in the room there's no one else
in the room and the fact that he's even
there and it hits him then then he's
like oh god what am i doing it's like oh
man you were oh you were almost there oh
good a Bieber yeah be like what you say
marriage is hard read this read this you
want to know you want to know you're the
actual marital problems
read this dude we're 12 years deep and I
let her peg me just to keep things just
to keep things healthy eat my turds
god forbid with dude with how [ __ ]
horny and [ __ ] off we are from the
internet and porn that's gonna be
everybody when we're like 40 yeah I do
guarantee we're all gonna be resorting
to weird [ __ ] to keep stuff interesting
cuz it what like every dude and you know
select females watching this podcast or
listening to it well we're all corrupted
from [ __ ] I say selection I say select
women because women are smart they don't
engage porn yeah which is probably the
best thing huh because we we just
chuckle it like [ __ ] falling in a mouth
I've seen [ __ ] go close to my to her
mouth
yeah on the internet yeah yeah but there
are a lot of women who have never you
know no good because they you know porn
is like I feel like mo in most cases for
women it's like a special it's like a
thing they throw on once every yeah six
months just to be like you know ooh
let's let's be yeah and it's like
speaker K and they throw on the [ __ ]
you know the like softest [ __ ] you've
ever seen not that but like with the
vixen [ __ ] or whatever that super high
it's like reducing the glow effect on
everything
you know it's not like the immature
[ __ ] just yeah oh yeah dude with a
handheld camera pointing down it's like
there's an actual like crew and like an
editor does this thing on it yeah you
know oh man I would get too drawn into
those master prankster wasn't important
like a director oh man and these uses
beautiful anamorphic lenses and you get
this like nice just distortion on the
edges it's Noel Jack's off to the gear
yeah those videos yeah I just read the
camera list oh yeah you see the boom in
one of the shots and you keep going back
to that shot oh yeah I dipped it in a
frame what a [ __ ] getting off on the
blunders yeah I'm such a good film
director oh I'm so good at my job
my master creative uh yeah but yet dudes
are more of like a dudes are more like
porns like a normal thing yes is he
gonna now sumit [ __ ] it out yeah get to
the point where like you're casually on
a [ __ ] and you're just like no regular
porn just escapes you you're like you'll
saran wrap over hermit what is this I
mean I just got it even for 10 seconds
you know what's crazy is I think we're
in this you know it's crazy dude what's
crazy I feel like we're in this [ __ ] or
now we're definitely old
cuz I'm starting to get weird videos of
people being like you want a weird DM
here's a weird video and I'm getting
like old-ass porn clips that were like
when we were like [ __ ] 16 no way
yeah like you remember the one with the
with the chick like stuff and all the
cake in her [ __ ] what I don't think I
ever saw that one I think so I freaking
take darts I think it was cake farts oh
yeah I saw cake farts yeah and she's
like sitting in in
she ever like moshus it in there she
does she like sits on the cake pushes up
and she farts and then she sits on the
cake she sits up and she farts you think
Oh like it's like super pleasureful okay
for her some for some reason I thought
there was a portion which like flipped
it around it was just like mush in it
and like being disgusting I don't think
so I don't think that was ever part of
cake farts but whatever yeah and that
she didn't meatloaf farts remember that
use that okay I refuse that I was so bad
meatloaf already that's just I don't
like that oh yeah you know it's gross as
[ __ ] yeah but it was like that was like
a crazy that was only way she could have
topped herself Chris grossest meatloaf
yeah that's where I feel like I'm like
not as gross I've got not a full up dude
where I'm like I see nasty [ __ ] like
that and I just trusted I'm like yeah I
bet it's worse and I just don't engage
now like I saw like you know kids in the
sandbox and two girls one cup and you
know I heard about the ass and the like
the jar in the ass good I never bet that
one's bad yeah yeah so bad probably you
know we talked about it the claim that
the two girls one [ __ ] two girls one
[ __ ] was fake two girls on fart yeah
my brain has just melted no two girls
that was fake yeah I know yeah
apparently yeah whatever but yes I won
7k parts the other day so now I don't
know it's crazy to think that like I
would think there would be a whole new
generation of like [ __ ] up porn clips
and the fact that just all the classics
keep resurfacing yeah we just did it so
well our generation yeah our generation
just [ __ ] blew it out of the water
that nobody can top it because because
we did it yeah that was like this will
only get 50 views yeah uploading a video
to the Internet man I was gonna see this
yeah exactly it's just like you know
it's just gonna go on some random
website no one's ever gonna wait I'm
sorry what let's read it sorry
yeah let's read it I'm sorry yeah
on a flex and I'm holding half a bank
I'm trying to flex not trying to flex
take your fishing notion break that's
not a flex